hi everyone i'm rony i'm a phd student
at the department of computer science in
tel aviv university my advisors are amir
spielke and it's hacktamo
the title of this talk is nonlinear
repair of read solomon codes and this is
a joint work with its rakhtamo our work
deals with the repair problem
which is a problem
from a relatively new research area
called
coding for distributed storage systems
so let me first say what are distributed
storage systems
what is their goal
and how error correcting codes fit in
so the task of a distributed storage
system which is just a collection of
many nodes
is to store data reliably over long
periods of time
using this distributed collection of
storage nodes
now the problem is that individual
storage nodes can fail
and by failure i mean that the data that
was stored on these servers
is erased
now
since the data was erased we want to
recover it
and recovering erased data requires
redundancy
so the solution is basically use an
erasure correcting code
a code in this stock is a map from f q
to the k to f q to the n
and as we always do we abuse notation
and say that c is also
the image of such a map
now we say that c is a linear
code if it is a linear subspace of
dimension k
and the notation that we use is brackets
n k q code where n is the length of the
code words k is the dimension of the
subspace
and q
is the size of the alphabet and note
that fq here means the finite field of
order q
now in distributed storage systems we
always use mds codes
and mds codes have the following
property
and which is that the code can correct
from any n minus k erasures
so what is an erasure an erasure is
replacing a symbol by a question mark
so as you can see here
c1 and c2 were replaced by question
marks and c3 wasn't
now back to the property
the property states basically that if
someone takes my code word
and performs up to n minus k erasures
anywhere he wants
and he gives me back the result
then i can basically know
what the original code word was
and this process of decoding this
corrupted code word
is done efficiently in linear mds codes
so now after defining codes and mds
codes
we can see what is coding for
distributed storage system
so when you think about coding for
distributed storage systems you can
imagine the following scenario
you take a data which can be a file and
you cut it into k chunks of data
each such chunk is going to be a symbol
in a finite field of order queue
now these k symbols together
will be encoded to a single code word
using an mds code
so as you can see in the picture c1 c2
up to cn
is a code word
now each symbol in the code word is
going to be distributed to a different
server
okay so as you can see in the picture
c1 is stored inside s1 c2 is stored
inside s2 up to
cn which is stored in sm
i didn't say why we use mds codes
we use mds codes
since the trade-off between erasure
correction capability and storage
overhead in mds codes is optimal
as i said individual nodes can fail
so let's consider the following problem
we have n servers
that store our code word as before
and assume that the last server failed
at this point we bring a new server
called the replacement node
and this server
needs to replace the node that failed
and in this process the server needs to
recover the data that was on that server
an algorithm that recovers the lost data
from the remaining nodes is called the
repair scheme
if we look at the slide
we see that the nodes transmit to this
new replacement node
some function of the data that they
store
okay so let's see here
the server s1 transmits mu1 of c1
and up to the server n minus one let's
say transmits mu n minus one of c n
minus one
now this replacement node gets all these
values and recovers the data that was on
that server that failed
the repair scheme is called linear
if the mu i's which are the functions
that complete the data that is going to
be transmitted
are linear functions
and by linear i mean that they are
linear over the base field of the finite
field fq
the bandwidth of the scheme is the total
number of bits transmitted from the
nodes to the replacement node
if we look back
on this slide we see that the nodes
transmitted u1 of c1 up to mu n minus 1
of cn minus 1.
then the bandwidth is this sum and the
log is taken in the base of 2 since the
bandwidth is measured in bits
let me say here that all the logs in
this talk are going to be in base 2
and that for simplicity of notations we
shall avoid ceilings
the bandwidth is a parameter which we
want to minimize
and why we want to minimize the
bandwidth because in real life scenario
a replacement of a node requires a huge
amount of bandwidth
and why is that basically
a server stores a lot of data and not
only just one symbol as in our example
it stores a lot of symbols
if we manage to minimize the bandwidth
that is required
to recover a single symbol then we
minimize the bandwidth which is required
to
recover many symbols
and minimizing the bandwidth
will eventually increase the reliability
of the system and therefore
minimizing the bandwidth is a huge
problem
in the area of coding for distributed
storage systems this leads us to the
repair problem
[Music]
the goal is to design codes together
with repair schemes that have small
bandwidth and the requirement from these
repair schemes is to repair not only
the last node the nth node but also the
first the second basically repairing any
node
this problem was initiated in the paper
of the marquis godfrey wu weinright and
ramchandran in 2010
and this problem again is highly
relevant also in modern distributed
storage system for example google and
facebook already deploy in the storage
systems
codes
and even in this distributed storage
system the failure of a node is not a
rare incident it happens and when it
happens
the bandwidth
is a critical issue
so minimizing it is an important problem
in coding for distributed storage
systems
[Music]
first let's consider what is called the
trivial repair
okay so as we said before our codes are
mds codes
and the nds codes have the property that
it can recover from any n minus k erased
symbols
so equivalently
any k
servers any k nodes can send their
symbol to the replacement node
and the replacement node can compute the
entire code word and find out also what
was the failed symbol
right so in this example
the first k
servers transmit each one of them
transmit its symbol
so
the server that received all of these
values computed c1 up to cn
and therefore he knows what cn is
so let's examine the properties of this
repel
so it is linear since every server
transmitted
its symbol and the symbols came from
right finite field
the bandwidth is k times slope q where q
is the alphabet size
and the question is
is it optimal in terms of bandwidth
so the answer is no
the main idea to achieve small bandwidth
is to contact more than k nodes and
receive fraction of information from
each node
if we look at this example we'll think
of the situation where s1 let's say
sends half of the bits of c1
or for example s1 computes
a function of c1 and transmits only one
bit
okay and as it turns out contenting more
than k nodes and receiving fraction of
information from each node
can reduce the bandwidth
so in the same paper of the marquis at
al
they show the lower bound on the
bandwidth that is needed in order to
recover a lost node
and the bandwidth which is denoted by b
has to be at least this quantity where d
is the number of nodes that participate
in the repair and the literature it is
called helper nodes
now note that if we sign instead of d
way sine k
the bandwidth b has to be at least k
times log q and this matches the trivial
repel
note that in the trivial repair we
indeed contacted exactly k nodes
now
note that as d
starts to increase then this quantity
becomes much smaller
a code that achieves
this bound with a quality
for any
failed node
and using any set of the helper nodes
is called
nkdmsr code
now there are several msr codes with
linear repair schemes these are just
few examples
all of these constructions in order to
achieve
this bound with the quality they indeed
contacted more than k nodes
and received partial information from
each node
but none of these codes is the most
famous code which is the rit solomon
code
so what about red solomon so let's
briefly recall what are read solomon
codes
so we take n distinct points
in this finite field of order q
and we denote by f subscript k
all the polynomials the single variable
polynomials of degree at most k
then the code is defined by the
following map so i take a polynomial of
the great most k
and i map it to the evaluation vector
of this polynomial at these n
distinct points
and this is the nk curate solomon code
which is defined
with the evaluation points alpha 1 to
alpha n
now the question is why care about read
solomon codes
so read solomon codes are basically
everywhere
and in particular read solomon codes are
in current distributed storage systems
facebook uses read solomon code with
parameters
14 instead of n
and k equals 10.
so designing repair schemes for its
solomon codes with better bandwidth can
find immediate applications
in these storage systems
the repair problem of rich hormone codes
can be thought of as a new polynomial
interpolation problem recall that in the
classical interpolation problem we have
k distinct points
and we want to find the polynomial of
degree at most k minus 1 that goes
through all of these points
here the question becomes how much
information is needed
from the points f of alpha 1 up to f of
alpha n minus 1
in order to
determine f of alpha n
know that
in the classical interpolation problem
we need to find out the entire
polynomial while here
we need just to find out a single
evaluation point
so let us review some known results
the marquis and care
showed
the trivial repair
of
rs codes
is not optimal
basically they gave examples of linear
repair schemes with better bandwidth
then guru summit waters gave a complete
characterization of linear repair
schemes through solomon codes
let me note here
that if linear repair schemes
of read solomon codes outperform the
trivial repair scheme in terms of
bandwidth then it means
that the code must be defined over
a field extension
and why is that
let us look at
this slide here and see that for the mu
eyes to be linear
it must be that the mu eyes are
functions from a field to a subfield
then tamuya and barak showed that ice
codes are nkd msr codes for any k d and
n they gave explicit constructions of
such codes
the thing is that
their extension degree
was exponential
in n log n meaning that the field size
is something like 2 to the n to the n
and they proved an almost matching lower
bound that says that the extension
degree
has to be at least
exponential in k lo k and again if this
means that the finite field has to be of
order
2 to the k to the k
and this is invisible in practice
so the goal is reducing the alphabet
size
so how can we reduce the alphabet size
so
and guru swami showed that any msr code
not just
a read solomon codes
with linear repair scheme
must have large alphabet size
so what about non-linear repair schemes
can non-linear repair scheme help us
reduce the alphabet size
and our starting point was to look at
read someone codes over prime field
and why is that because
any repel scheme for read solomon codes
over prime field
that outperforms the trivial repair
scheme must be non-linear
this is because
there are no linear functions from a
prime field to a proper subset
of the prime field
so let me now introduce our results
so our main result is the first
non-linear repair scheme as far as we
know
the first
theorem is that almost all
two-dimensional reit solomon codes over
prime fields
are asymptotically n2 dmsr codes for any
d
and i'll define in second what
asymptotically means
[Music]
the second theorem is a construction
and it holds for any k
and d up to n over two
we give an explicit construction of rs
codes where every node
can be repaired with bandwidth that
asymptotically achieves the cursor bound
we know that this construction
falls from being an msr code
because
it doesn't hold for any
set of d helper nodes and by
asymptotically in both theorems we mean
that the bandwidth achieves the cuts
bound plus an additive factor that
depends on n
and why we call it asymptotically
because in coding for distributed
storage we think of the alphabet size as
being larger
than n the number of servers
we also prove a new lower bound
on the bandwidth that is required to
repair a node
when the code is read solomon codes over
prime fields
if we have an nk read solomon codes over
prime field
then to repair a node
every node must transmit at least
this quantity of bits
and note that
the first term corresponds to the cuts
at bound
and the second term is our improvement
of the cuts at bound this quantity is
small but it says that we cannot
get as close as we want to the cuts at
bound
we now discuss the intuition behind our
non-linear repair
assume that we have these functions mu i
such that the repair of the nth node
succeeds then these functions are
from this finite field of prime order
to some subset now the pre-images of new
i for every element in the subset
give a partition of the prime field
of size
a
when we look at the data transmitted
from the servers to the replacement node
we can think that the servers basically
transmitted the following sentence
c2
belongs to the third set induced by the
partition of mu2 okay so instead of
thinking about functions
we will think about partitions
[Music]
so now i'm going
to describe the proof idea
let's look at the following partition of
fp
okay so i start with the first group are
just the numbers zero to t minus one
a one are the numbers from t to two t
minus one and we continue this way
so note that every set in the partition
is of size t
except for the last set which is of size
less than t
[Music]
now i'm going to describe how the repair
scheme for the nth node looks like
so i take n minus 1
elements in my finite field which are
not zero
then i'm going to define a partition of
fp
for every distinct node
so the node that stored c1
is going to have the following partition
gamma 1 times a0 this is the first set
of its partition then gamma 1 times a1
the second set of its partition and so
on now c2
is going to have a different partition
that depends on gamma 2. so gamma 2
times a 0 is going to be the first set
and
we continue this way
so that every node will have its own
partition which is defined by the gammas
now note when i say
an element times a set
then i mean that i
multiply each element of the set with
this element
now the repair scheme is going to be the
following simple process
each node
is going to send me
the index
of the set that the symbol belongs to
so let's say for example that c1
belonged to the first set
in the partition of gamma 1
and c2 belongs to the third set in the
partition of
gamma 2. then every server transmitted
me the index of the set
so the first node transmitted 0 then the
second node transmitted 2 and the last
node here transmitted s minus 1.
now i'm going to phrase a condition
such that if the condition holds
then the repair succeeds
so the condition is as follows so i take
two distinct code words in c
if on both c and c prime the nodes
transmit the same values it must be
that they agree on
the last value meaning that c n equals c
n prime
so if we look back here then suppose we
have c and c prime then
consider the case where c one and c one
prime belonged to the first set
c two and c two prime belonged to the
third set and so on then if they agree
on the last coordinate then the repair
succeeds okay and this makes sense
when i think about read summon codes
then i can picture this condition
and see that this condition basically
says the following
so for any two polynomials
that on alpha one the value on alpha one
is inside this set and the value on
alpha two is inside this set and so on
up to n minus 1
then the condition states that on alpha
n the polynomials agree
what we did in our work is we
phrased an even simpler condition
okay we worked with this condition
so what the condition says for every
code word
if it holds that for any j up to n minus
1 c j belongs to the set
gamma j times the interval from minus t
to t
then c n must equal zero
so this is the condition
and the proposition states the following
so if the condition holds then the
repair of cn succeeds and the bandwidth
is n minus 1 times log to the base of 2
ceiling of p over t
first let's see why this is the
bandwidth this is the bandwidth since
recall that every node sends us the
index of the set
so to represent this number
we need it most
log of the number of sets and the number
of sets is p over t
let's prove the proposition now
i assume towards the contradiction that
the repair does not work
so this means basically that i have two
code words
such that on both the nodes
return the same set indices
and that c n does not equal c n prime
meaning that they they do not agree on
the last coordinate
i defined the difference of these code
words and know that since the code is
linear then c double prime
is a legal code word it holds that
c j double prime
for any j between 1 and n minus 1
belongs to this set gamma j times the
interval from minus t to t
therefore we got a contradiction to our
condition
this is a contradiction to our
conditions since
c double prime
on all the indices from 1 to n minus 1
belongs to this set of gamma j times
minus t to t but
on the last coordinate it does not equal
zero
so our condition does not hold
note that in the third bullet we used
the structures of our sets in the
partition
recall what our sets are
okay so these were our sets now the
partition
was just taking some element
and multiplying it with every set
so if i take two elements let's say in
gamma one a two
and i do one element minus the other
then since a2 has the elements from two
t
to
three 3t minus 1 then when i do one
element minus the other
then i'm the interval from minus t to t
okay so
let's go back
so what we need
we need to show that there are alpha one
to alpha n evaluation points
by which we define our read solomon
codes
and values gamma one to gamma n minus
one for which the condition holds
also need to maximize t
in order to achieve small bandwidth okay
as t gets larger the bandwidth gets
smaller
now note that i showed you a condition
for repairing the the nth node
the condition can be formulated such
that all the nodes can be repaired but
each node requires different
gammas
so this is exactly what we did in our
work
for the open questions we have the
immediate open question to construct
or show existence of rs codes over time
field that are asymptotically msr codes
so note we show that almost all
two-dimensional read solomon codes over
prime field
are asymptotically msl code
and in terms of constructions we
provided a construction
for larger values of k
that
even though they have good repair
properties
they are not msr codes
and another interesting open question is
to better understand the tension between
p the field size
and k or n the dimension or the length
of the code
and we
know that
there is
a connection between
our work on repairing read solomon codes
and the leakage resilience of shamir
secretary schemes
so better understanding the tension
between p and k
has applications
in that field also
thank you for listening and hope to see
you in the live session